you know you guys are seeing 700 percent
growth by some metrics how do you keep
that kind of growth up well you know
we're lucky to have a great partner in
Google Capital and we're excited about
this particular round we've seen
tremendous growth as you mentioned over
the last several years we've got some
world-class customers and as you know
you can't pick up a newspaper without
seeing another breach and that's really
been driving this this overall
environment for the security marketplace
and when you couple that with the fact
that existing and legacy technologies
are just not capable of dealing with
this advanced threat it really is a
fantastic opportunity for a company like
CrowdStrike so Jeanne how does this play
into your other investments at Google
Capital late stage investments
technology that's not supposed to
compete with Google that's right
I think I guess for most from a Google
perspective security is something that
the company takes very seriously it's
obviously foremost on our mind as we
protect users and customers customers so
we're Google doesn't disclose who it has
relationships with but certainly
CrowdStrike is very well-known to Google
and and the environment more broadly
Thanks I was gonna ask you so one of the
things that I'm a longtime consumer and
occasionally maker of security products
especially during the PayPal years one
of those truisms in computer security is
people would love to pay for the day
after the attack has successfully
occurred on their network how are you
finding your sales process your ability
to convince people if this is something
they finally need to pay attention to
and I'm sure the newspaper coverage of
all the incidents including the
government helps but what's changing the
environment how are things changing on
the buying side of security products so
hard you take that
yeah well if you look at where security
has been and where it is today it really
is a board level discussion and I think
that's one of the big drivers and
changes that we've seen the board is
very concerned with their brand
reputation the relationships with
customers the exposure and the cost of a
data breach and that's being being
driven top-down into these companies so
years ago we would have to really
evangelize security now it's very
topical at the board meetings and board
members are asking some tough questions
and making sure that their companies are
focused on security so that's really
been a big boost for us and the security
industry in general now gene looking at
some of the other companies in google
capital's portfolio SurveyMonkey
Glassdoor how are you evolving the
strategy at Google Capital what what is
the strategy because you know for
example Google Ventures recently you
know did an earlier investment in uber
and then over started doing self-driving
cars and Waze is doing ride-sharing so
now they're they're sort of competing
with each other to a certain extent
what's the strategy at Google so our
mission is to focus on financial returns
that's what Google wants to see us
deliver that's how our performance is
measured and our strategy to do that is
to try to find sectors where Google can
bring expertise in the form of our
people to really support companies to
grow rapidly and so in general
CrowdStrike would be a very good example
of exactly the kind of company that we
like to invest in that really has a
focus not so much on doing anything that
Google is doing per se but we're fellow
travelers in the technology space and
and and we're able to support the
company ways that are differentiated
relevant typical financial investment
and what's your take on the environment
right now our valuations frothy from
your perspective yeah I think you know
it's not terribly controversial to say
the valuations seem like they're they're
relatively frothy having said that there
are a number of very high-quality
companies that were excited to be
involved with and and so it's an
interesting time that guys
so as CrowdStrike the latest unicorn
what's the valuation we're talking about
here all that George comes jeana's
deferred from new Georgie
yeah we're not specifically giving out
exact numbers but I would say
approaching unicorn status is a great
way to characterize it okay and what
about your plans to go public well you
know at this point we've got a lot of
opportunity in front of us and really
what we're focused on is customer
acquisition geographic expansion
building out our Falcon platform and
redefining the endpoint security market
where other players like antivirus
technologies are just falling down